all right so we're looking at the
phenomenology of spirit we're looking at
a very very tiny portion of it right now
the introduction and what's and while
they're supposed to do in their
introduction usually you guys read a lot
of text in your classes do you know to
skip the introduction I know I skipped
quite a few introductions why why do you
just get that reductions yeah this
generally just sets everything up to
bring you in okay yeah it's a set up if
they're if their book is understandable
by itself you should probably be able to
like to figure out what it ought to be
in the introduction after you've read
the book all right any other reasons you
don't read introductions yeah this too
long
you know like a 100 page introduction to
a 40 page book that's probably
imbalanced yeah that happens sometimes
any other reasons I don't read it
sometimes I'm lazy admittedly yeah I
have to do a lot reading like you do the
students and so I'm kind of selective in
what I'm gonna read the introduction to
and what I've not like to you could read
the phenomenology of mine or
phenomenology spirits how you translate
Geist the German word without reading
the introduction and I think you could
get a lot out of it but Eagle is giving
you these sort of keys to his method in
part in that that very short
introduction and Hegel's philosophy is a
bit different than what you guys have
been encountering so far Hegel is
writing at a time when philosophy is
particularly white in the sense that
morning it's been developing you know
something consciously for quite a while
I think about the very first text that
we started reading or Plato but you
could go even further back before
we call the pre-socratics philosophy has
a long history philosophers respond to
each other they write about each other
and take each other's ideas into account
by the time that Hegel is writing it's
been going on for over 2,000 years and
there had been some recent challenges
people that we haven't read in this
class that Hegel is responding to like
Immanuel Kant who said look the whole
history metaphysics and of morals up
until this point is basically been a
history of mistakes I'm going to try to
set it on a right path once and for all
and usually anytime somebody says that
they're gone that once and for all what
actually happens is that that subtle
everything it's a mess
yeah just adds more to the puzzle you
know and now you've got one more ISM one
more type of philosophy one more person
to read they claim to you know solved
everything or these outline the whole
program and it turns out that that's not
really the case now Hegel is the kind of
guy and I think some of you are in this
sort of load who wants to know about
everything who wants to figure out how
everything gets together he uses this
word that you came across very early
enough and you were like well what is
that the absolute you know that's a good
question
and Hegel's not going to actually get a
great answer
he in this little section that were
reading he's presuming that he has some
sort of background knowledge about this
when we're talking about the absolute we
mean something like you know the whole
or
meaning or what is that what is the most
meaning hole you know when if you're
asking questions about what's the
meaning of life you're in a certain
sense asking absolute questions what is
everything made up
that's question about the absolute what
am I gonna eat for breakfast after class
that's not a question about the
absolutely see the big difference
between them what should I do with my
life is that a question about the
absolute or isn't that a question about
the absolute it could go either way
you know if you're saying what should I
do with my life because I want to make a
ton of money and money is really
important money makes the world go
around etc etc etc we might say that's
that's you know just talk about it about
but not all things well actually let's
talk about the absolute if you think
that money is the be-all and end-all by
which everything is measured money is
for you and absolute now there's
something to that that's that's a
grander way of thinking than just saying
hey I want to make a buck isn't it
somebody who actually believes that
money is the most important thing in the
world and they try to understand
everything in terms of money that's a
real project isn't that's kind of
admirable somebody who thinks of the
meaning of life in terms style and
living the most artistic rich full
experientially diverse life possible
that will also be a stance about the
absolute that's talking about what is
what is greatest what is best when you
say you know what everything consists in
those are statements about the absolute
as well and the goal is to figure out
what actually is there's saying the yeah
absolutely you notice there's a lot of
interest in this
right some people do think that money is
the way to evaluate everything other
people think that something like a
religious standpoint would provide you
with the keys to understanding
everything and there's a lot of
different alternatives out there as far
as that goes
some people think that human development
and making actual the potential that's
within us is what's absolute there's
it's a lot of different candidates or
this so how do we figure this out well
we have to have some way of going about
this because otherwise imagine that each
single one of you have been at this
moment got up and shouted what is most
valuable in your life at this point in
time or the classroom be like what's
that clear your answers would be all
over the place could any of you actually
pay any attention to anybody else's
answer while you're shouting at the top
of your lungs in a vehicle says probably
not it would be a pandemonium wouldn't
it like it would be like what William
James called the booming buzzing
confusion it would be hard to make sense
of so we want to look at things in a
somewhat different more orderly
systematic way and Hegel is adding a bit
more stuff to the next to Hegel is a
philosopher who thinks in terms of
development culture time and history so
now just think about this class this is
an introduction of philosophy class you
came in here and some of you had read
some of the people that we were going to
look at you know I remember the whole I
did at the very beginning who who's
heard anything about Plato's read Plato
Thomas Aquinas was one
had heard of the most and something
you'd actually read then we started
reading these guys in order in a sort of
chronological order we skipped a lot of
people and mentally but did you see any
any progress moving as we went from like
the ancient stuff into the medieval
stuff and into the modern stuff did you
see any progress being made or did it
just seem like just those guys mix this
and this guy thinks this this guy thinks
this and they're all kind of full of it
yeah very good yeah that's that's a sign
of progress when you can take somebody
else's viewpoint and go beyond it by
because ever heard that expression
standing on the shoulders of giants yeah
you know if you're not a giant then you
see how much go over the giant you still
see further that's how it does don't you
right even if you're just a tiny little
dwarf you would see further than that
giant us and Aristotle is one of those
kind of Giants from Cicero
you know Augustine maybe we're not
actually smarter than that on our own
individually but you know somebody like
Hitler would say well you know we've
made some progress beyond them the very
fact that you know you can get Aristotle
in the Aristotle you can buy this works
in like you know the Greek in English on
face book pages is about this long of a
shelf you get another book about this
thick you know that's got that kind of
paper that they all would use for Bibles
that very thin paper you know so you can
pack a lot into it now you could you
could do that or you could pick any
other philosopher you like or any other
think about any other thinker who's got
something to say about what is most
important what
while Maya there might be a historian it
might be a person at literature might be
a poet it might be somebody in your
field who actually wrote something
interesting theoretical what makes
people tick sooner or later they're all
doing philosophy as soon as you start
getting to a certain level of thought
you're doing philosophy and there is
progress that's being made and Eagle
wants to try to figure out what does
this all mean
the absolute can change over time frame
they can grow so word he would say in
many respects in a better position than
say Plato books or even Augustine ones
or through Hegel today I suppose you'd
say we're in a better position today
than Hegel himself once so this idea of
progress or development
we call that dial-up somewhat different
use of the term than what exercise
meaning by us but nonetheless it's being
used that way
now you notice like that is a big word
under phenomenology and that here's
hails actual you know headline to this
the science of the experience of
consciousness that's what he is up to
this this work that's what you know the
introduction is about that's perfectly
clear right the science of the
experience of consciousness we
understand more or less what each of
those words mean that's a phonology is
and there you go everyone understands
perfectly no right only we're that
simple
let's look at each one of these in turn
so you have this big Greek sounding word
phenomenology you guys know from long
you know go back in your elementary and
middle school days whenever you got an
ology what does that mean science or the
study yeah very good
so biology study of life BOS is life so
you've got this big word of phenomena
when we say phenomenon we often don't
use it in a technical term we just mean
something that is happening or something
you want to talk about why sometimes we
trotted out when we want to sound a
little bit erudite so instead of saying
you know i would like to talk about the
traffic that's out there on nine and how
people drive too fast you know it's a
40-mile thousand thirty here right
thirty or forty thirty so it's a 30s
zone here and it's a forty zone back
there and people are driving 60 and 50 I
don't like that now if you want to sound
a little bit erudite you could say I
would like to talk about the phenomenon
of people driving faster than is
warranted by conditions just by adding
that word phenomenon in there it sounds
a little bit higher level doesn't but
all phenomena
means is what here's what we notice well
you could just as well say I've been
noticing that people drive awfully fast
on that road out there way over the
speed limit myself included some of the
time especially better watch it I've got
one of those cars where it can go you
know pretty fast if I'm not paying
attention to it
phenomenology means sort of the study of
appearances the study of what it is that
we perceived how the things actually
appear to us this might say why would
you need a science about that aren't you
perceiving stuff already yeah that's a
legitimate you know worry right there
yeah that's one key there's a difference
between what we call appearance and then
reality right and we have had cases
where what something appears to us at
first turns out not to be the case now
how do you know that it's not the case
though a new appearance comes up right
something else appears to you something
else by you you think for example that
this is coffee you take a sip
it smells like coffees you're taking a
sip and then it tastes like kerosene
like that as kerosene tastes pretty bad
shouldn't get in the habit of drinking
kerosene I hope people by the way who's
to gargle with Karis
they get sick not a good idea now how do
you know that well you're expecting one
phenomenon and you experience a
different phenomenon all we have Haga
would say is a whole chain of candid
appearances appearing to us that we take
it when you find out that a friend is no
longer the person that you thought them
to be you know there was an appearance
right and sometimes people human beings
deliberately project an appearance
that's not the reality is one of the
cases I'll give you an example from what
I was the student myself I had a hard
time staying at staying awake in class
when I was a student at times and there
are certain dodges that you can do to
try to appear like and you guys know
that it feels like your eyelids start
drooping having trouble keeping them
open what else you know you get that
fuzzy kind of feeling you lose a sense
of time the words that are being said
and become disconnected so what do you
do to make sure that the professor
doesn't think that you're actually
falling asleep well you can't shake your
eyes a bit like this and go like this
right then they can't see that your eyes
are closed
definitely don't put your head down on
your desk because that gives it away
find some things stare fixedly at like
you're deep in thought you know not
every once in a while but you're paying
close attention
that's an appearance right that's an
appearance that you're deliberately
projecting what's the reality in that
case
yeah your your your checked out right
and how does the professor know that
something else might happen like
suddenly your head falls or like you're
falling asleep well you could have
phenomena that are not expected but we
do expect most of the stuff in our
experience to be about the same so yeah
it doesn't necessarily have that
cavitation I suppose there could be some
discourses in which that's that's an
unexpected phenomena yeah they're a
phenomenal player you know they're
phenomenal warrior yeah that has that
you're right that has a connotation of
like being amazed by something we're
being amazed when we're experiencing
something unexpected side I think
that'll make sense well so let's come
back to this now so what appears what we
take notice of that can change over time
we can acquire better understanding of
what's out there by having better
appearances more reliable appearances
but really all we have to work on our
appearances now he's got this thing the
science of the experience of
consciousness so each one of these terms
is important bad consciousness right
start with the very last thing every one
of you for Hegel is consciousness in the
sense that he's talking about
you are a conscious human being even if
you weren't a human being you would be
conscious of your environment but we
human beings are conscious of not only
of our environment but also much more we
have the inner life don't - don't you
have your own perceptions your feelings
your memories you sometimes take
about that think for example case where
something that we use an unpleasant
memory because those are easier to
oftentimes to recall think of a case in
high school where you were you were
embarrassed for one reason or another
way to bet that every single one of you
your high school set of experiences
includes at least one experience right
college probably does do already know
what's going on when you remember that
where was that memory before sedimented
somewhere in you right we would often
say well it was like stored in your
brain cells and the physical explanation
of it there's other ways to explain it
you're remembering who's that memory
about what's that who's it about
it's your memory right who's what's the
memory who is the person that's memories
about it's a memory of you being
embarrassed
it's not you remembering yourself a
previous self who is yet at the same
time the same person as you are
otherwise you can't do you have any
memories like that where it doesn't
embarrass you anymore you're like yeah
they're really embarrassed at the time
but now I couldn't care less maybe there
is a you know enough of a distance
there's the feeling that that's no
longer me if you don't have that if you
actually remember it and you feel
embarrassed again then you are being
conscious of something in your inner
life something that no longer exists of
a past that is long gone but still has
presence for you again the presence
that's amazing that's just one thing
that you do routinely you drop the
shopping list you're probably not
thinking yeah I'm doing philosophy
you know I'm just going and getting you
know whatever it is if you're gonna get
some flour milk eggs you know
Pringles whatever it is that you get you
are orienting yourself towards your
environment when you draw up a list
you're making a plan for your son we
take these things for granted but we
don't realize just how much thinking
it's going on in all this when you
become infatuated with somebody you're
thinking about them all the time
they have become what Hegel says an
object for you and you not only have
mental representations of them you know
you like thinking about them you know I
saw them at the coffee shop and you know
they smiled at me and that smile was
such a great smile and you know all that
sort of stuff right you also have
feelings that come about those feelings
somehow get infused into the very
thoughts that you have about the person
the images that you're working with you
have desires expectations I wonder if I
should call them and be able to send a
text
what should I text them that's all
consciousness when you're working in
your classes and you're thinking about
how am I going to write this paper that
you know I just got the assignment sheet
for and I have no interest whatsoever in
this subject and I admittedly have not
been listening as well as I have been so
I'm not quite sure you know what the
teacher is looking for they're an awful
teacher - I have no idea how to possibly
please them and get out of this class
that I can I have two weeks left in that
might be the case for some of you right
again
that's all consciousness all these
things together are consciousness and
you notice I've described a whole bunch
of activities that are distinctively
human they take us beyond the merely
animal and every one of us is capable of
them every one of us does these fairly
routinely without thinking about them
but if we want to
we could actually pay attention to them
we could actually watch our
consciousness taking place and there's a
lot of techniques for doing this some
are associated with philosophy some are
associated with religion some are just
associated with you know various
training techniques things like that
some are associate action with writing
techniques but they all involve paying
attention to consciousness so that
brings us to this point of experience
now Hegel has a very particular way of
talking about experience that he says
this is a little bit different than what
you would ordinarily expect when we're
talking about experience so I'm going to
actually move you know very far into the
introduction
she says consciousness it grasps not
only the object that it's thinking about
it also grasps itself that sees whether
there's no that an accord or a discord
between the object in itself
consciousness develops over time there's
there's all sorts of distinctions that
he's making along those lines and then
he says when we're thinking about the
standards that we bring to to look at
these things the science by leaving a
lot of the standards that would be
normally bringing the side by a
vegetable just you know taking it into
ourselves paying close attention to
what's going on we're unable to treat
and discuss a subject as it actually is
in itself and for the for itself in its
complete reality so for Hegel you know
we can get beyond the appearances we get
more appearances but that's okay now how
does this have to do with experience he
says this dialectic process does he mean
by that
there's development there's a process by
which you're moving up from once
to the next so think for example about
where you are now as a student just
think about their skills as a student
what are the key skills that you need to
have that are gonna make it as a student
in classes yeah that's more of a
characteristic what are some of the like
basic operations the skills of you okay
so let's just take reading and writing
with me on the side because that gets
very complicated quickly there's a lot
of interesting theories about that a lot
of classes have you doing reading right
I imagine that most of you are pretty
good readers by this point how many of
you started out as a great readers few
of you might have how many of you had it
develop as readers okay how did that
happen you went from a lower stage to a
better stage to a better stage did that
happen just sort of like taking you know
one piece of machinery out of your brain
and putting another piece of the way
human minds work did it happened just by
you being placed in different contexts
and sort of like a fish you know in
different environments you just sort of
figured out oh I'm no longer the river I
better you know adjust to the lake then
you probably had some struggle right did
you have to think about did you ever
learn techniques for reading what those
include like taking notes writing
questions outside what do you guys do to
read well I don't know they teach you
guys these days
please don't walk well that's that's
very helpful yeah the more you read and
the better stuff you read the better a
reader you become a better writer too by
the way but also there are other
techniques that they taught you that at
first you were like oh
I can't stand doing this but then after
a while you're like wow this actually
pays a lot for me and then after a while
I'm part of your nature and then you
know you can actually get to the point
where you give them a trouble turning it
on
that's dialectical development you
contain the old where you used to be but
now you move to a higher stage you can
still do things at the lower level you
can still read just for pleasure right
all learning all these techniques of
studying and reading has not turned it
off so that you can't pick up a book
that you don't have to read for class
and actually enjoy what you're reading
if that happens
something's going wrong something
screwed screwed up along the way
but you've managed to go to higher and
higher stages you've encapsulated within
itself so he says this dialectical
process was consciousness executes on
itself on its knowledge as well as on
its object in the sense that out of the
new out of it the new mature object
arises is precisely what is termed
experience so then he talks and very
what you'd call metaphorical but he's
actually being quite technical terms a
little bit later he says the new object
the new thing that you're thinking about
now object doesn't necessarily have to
mean an object like this the object
could be your own processes of
understanding it could be the history of
something that could be the object
whatever it is that you're thinking
about the new object contains the
nothingness of the first the new object
is the experience containing that first
object so that's what weird way to
talking contains the nothingness of the
first you know like you have a box of
nothing that's very easy to get I just
get yourself a box it's already got
nothing in it
he doesn't mean nothingness in that
sense and we'll come back to that in a
moment so he says in the treatment of
this course of experience there's an
element in virtue of which it does not
seem to be an agreement with what is
ordinarily understood by
experience well we ordinarily think of
experiences just kind of wandering or
have feel this feel that oh there's a
set of keys
oh there you got colors within my pocket
nothing is connected right nothing is is
a systematic conjoined hole that makes
sense just a bunch of things all strung
together does your life sometimes feel
like that particularly when you're tired
or stressed out you're having a lower
level of experience than more than what
Hegel's talking about so he says on the
view above given the new object is will
this seem to have come about my
transformation or a conversion of
consciousness itself this way of looking
at the matters are doing what we
contribute when for example you decided
to come to college and at first it might
have been because you know you you are
expected to go to college right I think
I'm most of you at least come from
households where that is the basic
expectation if you're not doing in
college they might know what the hell
are you planning to do right and so it's
kind of a path that that's more or less
set out for you there's also other you
know impetuses the guidance counselor's
probably told you if you don't go to
college you're gonna you know have a
dead-end job and an unsatisfactory life
because you're going to show you the
statistics college graduates tend to
earn more than and high school graduates
all that sort of stuff
that may have gotten things going but
are you at the point now where you have
sort of thought it through and realized
yet this is where I belong I actually do
want to be in college this is this makes
sense for me this is something that I
can get behind as an autonomous person
not just as somebody who's being driven
by outside forces yeah that's that's
consciousness and that is you making a
decision
about yourself which is you engaging in
what Hegel's calling experience yeah if
you can tell yourself something like you
know I used to think that going to
college was just what I had to do is mom
and dad wanted me to do that or you know
I used to think that it was the smart
thing to do
just because I need to get a good job
because the economy's tough but I don't
want to live in a studio apartment my
entire life eating ramen those sorts of
things you still retain that that's
still part of who you you were what you
were thinking and now you say it but my
thinking has progressed beyond that I
now realize that there's something
worthwhile here for me something
intrinsically valuable that I want to
learn or I want to do you could even be
like you know I found a circle of
friends that I actually enjoyed the
English it doesn't necessarily have to
be something academic but there's
something that you're able to say I'm at
a higher level
that's what Hegel's long experience the
higher level does not completely get rid
of the lower level this is what when
you're studying about the nothingness
from the perspective of the lower level
the higher level is nothing but it turns
out not to be nothing it turns out to be
everything it turns out to be what puts
everything else into perspective your
life is going to be a whole series of
experiences like that it was great
that's part of what makes life so
interesting and we can share these with
each other too by the way it's not just
a matter of our own individual
experiences like that we can have group
experiences like that we can experience
that as a culture with us is how this is
all civilizations improve and also how
many they can decline so he talks about
the experience and consciousness he has
concerning itself and he says now if
we're serious about
this that has to embrace everything this
is where you might depart from hate this
is where you might say yeah you know I
followed you so far I can't like the
stuff that you're saying experience okay
now I got a better understanding of it
it means having like these stages where
the higher stage contains the lower
stage and yet surpasses it that sounds
great but do I really have to embrace
nothing less than the entire system of
consciousness the whole realm of the
truth of mine and in such way that the
moments of truth are set forth and
they're specific and peculiar character
that they here possess anybody has their
project now now yeah I mean if you did
you'd be Hegel that's why Hegel wrote
this book the phenomenology he was
trying to make sense out of everything
he was trying to state yeah so we he
says that consciousness good he's trying
to build upon itself as you go and it
retains all of the previous ones but you
are beyond that and you go for higher
levels yeah what was it except he says
embrace nothing less than the entire
system of consciousness so what that
would mean is actually trying to
understand not just your consciousness
and your own development but all the
important moments of development that
have taken place through the history of
mind civilization culture up to the
point where you exist because you're
actually a product of that so that would
mean sort of you know this vast
retrospective trying to figure out how
did we end up here that's a big project
so he's not dipping into the history not
just dipping into it
for Hegel philosophy is what is going to
unite all of the other disciplines that
study you
being history economics political theory
psychology all of those have their place
within this giant vast to galleon system
again this is one of those places where
you know you might get on the Hegel
train this far and let's say ah this is
the station where I joke ah right
the notion that we have to have a full
systematic understanding of everything
Hegel thought he supplied that in this
book with an ontology of spirit but it's
about this thing so you know a lot of
stuff going on there he also seemed to
think that history ended at 1807 which
is when he published the phenomenology
of spirit that all the essential changes
transformations shapes of consciousness
and all more or less been developed by
that point that would be another place
where you would probably say oh well
Hegel you know you got some things
perhaps right but that that one you're
probably wrong about you know did
history history in the sense of
meaningful history or something
radically new comes on the scene did
that really end in 1807 with Napoleon
you know in the Battle of Vienna who was
supposed to be immediately fighting at
the very time that he's finishing the
proofs for the phenomenology which may
not be true probably duh right I mean we
think that history is still going human
beings are still developing in important
ways but you wouldn't have to
necessarily abandon everything that
Hegel sang to know at that point what's
I was going to actually walk through
these sort of guiding questions but
let's actually look they add just a few
of the things that are going on in this
introduction I can see that we're not
going to actually get through all of the
introduction which is kind of funny
the short piece and it is in fact
supposed to be just an introduction so
it should be easy to get your but I got
taken too much time with examples let's
look at where he's actually starting in
this this this introduction so we have a
schematic we want knowledge and we're
trying to study the conditions of
knowledge how does it may actually come
to know things and what do we know these
aren't conservative he's using here he's
using consciousness right yeah
in this case it's absolute or it can be
any other object of knowledge and
knowledge is some sort of relationship
between the subject and the object he
starts off by talking about two ways
that we often conceive of knowledge
knowledge is some sort of instrument or
knowledge is some sort of what are we
invited instrument well we don't think
about instruments that you use to
acquire knowledge how do you in fact
experience the world that you want to
know about some things you don't really
need an instrument right
the instruments inside of you is there a
person in front of the room walking
right now if you were to doubt them
let's say you'd actually thought now
maybe he's a hologram you phoned it in
today is there a way you could test that
would four projectors there's a simpler
way get up walk up to me like polka
means yellow agency solid you know and
then well maybe you know dr. Sadler
actually used his robot you know dr.
Salvin and sent him in to teach the
class with some pre-recorded lecture
well they're instruments by which you
can acquire knowledge about things these
are kind of silly examples but think of
other instruments how do you know what
to wear for for going outside on any
given day look outside yeah if it's
sunny well yeah okay you check the
weather what is that we east that's one
of those things we take for granted it's
part of our natural attitude it's part
of our culture I just check the weather
I mean that's something that we have
available to us that that people you
know long ago did they would have to
just like look outside and kinda hope
for the best we can check the weather
it's gonna rain later today with a 50%
chance how do they know that I mean you
might say well they actually don't know
that they're off in July but mostly they
actually do know that how do they know
that yeah
weather pattern sources those okay so
that's that's really good there's an
entire system of instruments that they
use and they correlate together that get
them to be almost 50 percent accurate a
lot of the time which is pretty good for
meteorology given how complex the
weather actually is in the old days you
just have the Farmers Almanac and you'd
consult that and that was almost as good
as nothing really except for growing
seasons now here's the interesting thing
to think about does an instruments when
you apply it to know something do
instruments leave the thing that you're
trying to know intact or do they
sometimes modify
think about for example of microscope
you guys all remember putzing around
microscopes in biology in high school
what did you have to do in order to get
something on that microscope yeah it
focus it okay that's that's operating
machinery itself could you look at
anything it could be like say Apple look
at this we had real close-up you stick
it under there
why couldn't you just stick that under
there ah very good you have to be
prepared a certain way instruments
require that what it is that they're
looking at be modified to fit that
instruments and oftentimes we don't
realize this that we're contributing
something to the thing that we're trying
to know and sometimes modifying in the
process so what is our knowledge
actually up is our knowledge actually
have the thing itself words our
knowledge in some respects an artifact
that we create by the application of our
instrument yes can't you say that our
knowledge is just based off of
we take that small piece of something
yeah modified sir deserve it and then
take any you know we got learn from that
slice and apply as the whole yeah I mean
we do that in fact the question is
whether that's actually knowledge or
whether that's just sort of some
position on the basis that the part in
the whole must resemble each other quite
a bit and you know we're also still
modified that part of memory now you
know another possibility would be
knowledge is more like a medium what
does he mean by a medium think of the
air in this this classroom is the air in
this classroom interfering with you
seeing me or hearing me the sound waves
are being transmitted to your your ears
is the is the sound muffled because of
the air is it being modified in any way
or are you getting a clear signal yeah
marginal degree yeah and you can see me
just fine right because we have life and
we're not smoking in here you know to
two generations ago students you can
actually smoke while you're teaching
when I was in undergrad we would light
up right after class ended in the
classroom it sounds crazy there are
professors when not when I was a student
but two generations ago who would
lecture and they'd be smoking the whole
time then people would be sitting back
there smoking now imagine the he's in
Atlanta serve with like five or six
people smoking it'd be harder to see
right some media end up deforming the
signal that you're getting think about
our media imagine social media like
Facebook are you ever getting a really
impression of things through the
information that you're getting on
Facebook let's think about profile
pictures going to profile pictures truly
represent the people who they they are
profile pictures on in just in a visual
way I mean you can you can look at them
like yeah that's that's also that's a
really good picture of that they they're
quite attractive so people put up ugly
profile pictures most of the time that
we're gonna say no people will be like
well here's my good side and all right
let's get the lighting just right and
then a lot then they'll modify it even
more by using some instruments right
like Instagram or Picasa or whatever you
like some people I think Photoshop their
pictures yeah take out you know the
wrinkles or the blemishes or stuff like
that
so then you you have to be a little bit
suspicious of some media in their
ability to just you know communicate the
reality to us directly and eagle says
you know knowledge in general we can
understand it with either of these these
these models and we can start worrying
about this we can start being concerned
with what he calls this fear of falling
into error how do we know that we're
actually getting this straight you know
straight information that we're actually
getting true knowledge about the things
that we're trying to study not only
about things out there but sometimes
even about ourselves you know we have to
understand ourselves through instruments
in the media as well so he says this
fear of falling into error introduces an
element of distrust in the science with
which without any scruples of that sort
goes to work and actually doesn't know
it's not easy to understand why and so
we should place the distrust in this
very distressed and we should think
about what this fear of presuppose
something has truth he says it starts
with ideas of knowledge as an
instrumented as a medium presupposes a
distinction of ourselves from this
knowledge more most more especially it
takes for granted that the absolute
stands on one side and not put on the
other side cut off from the absolutely
Hegel saying all of these things
together are actually tied up together
that the absolutes or what it is that we
want to know is not something completely
separate from ourselves knowledge is not
something completely separate from
ourselves
I know it's often presented to us that
way in text books here's the textbook
textbook has information that's
knowledge it's your job to fill your
empty heads you know with that knowledge
but what's going on is actually much
more organic much more synthetic than
just simply you filling your head with a
bunch of data that works for computers
but your mind is not a computer in that
sense your mind is consciousness and
your mind is already by virtue of
thinking about these sort of things
extending itself through all of this
that's why objects can be phenomenal
that's why they can appear to you
because they're already within your
consciousness to a certain extent you
skip ahead a little bit
so he's worried about not falling into
[Music]
things that are right yeah what does he
mean by this our ordinary way of going
about things not seeing any sort of
mystery to to the world and to our own
processes of thinking about the world
just sort of taking everything as if
it's just the way it is and that's
that's just the you know how it how to
end up when in reality the way things
are is actually a product of very
complex historical forces that have been
going on for a long time then often you
have deep assumptions built into them
our first ways of responding to things
are not just something that comes just
from instinct or in nature it's
something that comes to us from where we
are in in history and in culture you
know think about the idea of fairness
how many of you like things to be fair
okay now some people take that as a
basic human you know reaction to things
if we look at history is that so basic
does it always have the same sort of
force in structuring social relations as
it does in our modern what we call
liberal democratic society I don't mean
in a political sense of like you know
associated with the Democratic Party or
progressivism I mean in the sense of
like being for rule of law each person
counting for for one moment all those
sorts of things that we take for granted
as part of our culture is that even the
case everywhere in the world is that
even the case everywhere in our culture
how many of you been told that one time
or another when you protest about
something life is not fair better get
used to it there's a contradiction there
isn't there with even within our own
culture where fairness is held up as
this absolute great value and yet even
within our own culture there are all
these pockets where we're told life's
not fair don't expect fairness that's
what Hegel calls a productive
contradiction and we'd go you know try
to build something out of that the
natural conscious natural consciousness
of things would just say well you know
you got your fairness over here and
you're not in fairness over here okay
that's it don't worry
but if you're a [ __ ] you know if you're
doing things philosophically you said
well that does worry me it's the same
culture right it's the same basic domain
for moral discussion shouldn't there be
some sort of consistency if mom and dad
are right about life is not fair and I
shouldn't expect fairness then you know
when my political science teacher starts
talking about basic you know fairness as
structuring society what's going on
one of those two better view right and
the other one wrong or else maybe both
of them are wrong is there some way in
which both of them can possibly be right
besides to say well you know you got
your mom and dad over here and they
handle things there and then you got
your you know your academic over here
and the two of them never meet
well they do meet because they're
meeting we're in you
you're experiencing dissonance you're
experiencing things not matching
important things and you have to figure
out how am I going to negotiate this
conflict between them you can't just
fall back into things so all that you
know always take take something for
granted now the opposite to this the
natural consciousness would be what
higgles bones cactuses and scepticism
says and we can't really know anything
not only shouldn't we take anything for
granted once we do stop taking things
for granted everything falls apart and
you've known people like this right
where they were very firm believers in
one way of seeing things and when that
worldview gets shaken like they gonna
walk the the reservation totally and go
crazy or they're like nothing matters to
me anymore I can't trust anything and
you find them you know involved with
something equally you know you're
rational later on because they had to
throw themselves into something before
they get to that they're a skeptic and
the skepticism is corrosive and
skepticism as a stance that people can't
take there's a distinct human
possibility for consciousness it's a way
for consciousness hegel things to assert
its own freedom as opposed to the object
you could say no to everything they can
say I don't believe you to everything
but is it this is productive well look
at you look at you as fire what do you
think No why not
yeah there you go when you when you to
say no to everything because everything
could possibly be wrong or misleading or
deceptive you have you actually do close
you're off close yourself off to things
and you are taking a stance without
seeming to take a stance right yeah you
won't be able to progress and Hegel is
all about consciousness progressing you
know there may be different times for
tackling different different topics you
know one example of this is I have
students who take you know the ethics
class when they're supposed to you know
in your junior and it's just not a good
time for them and then they come and
they think it's senior year and they're
like yeah and all this finally makes
sense together I can wrap my head around
this but imagine saying I'm never gonna
study any of this stuff because that
they could all possibly be deceptive
you would never make any progress
imagine doing that with Locke I'm never
going to love anybody because anybody
could be a deceiver never going to have
any of their romantic relationships
because you know not actually they're
all going to be bad they all could be
bad what would that like to be like
towards about 80 years old full of
regrets I imagine right and when it
would a life like that even be able to
generate a full understanding of how it
went long probably not it's only those
who've progressed who can have a full
understanding of where things go wrong
so he talks about natural consciousness
as something we want to avoid we also
want to avoid skepticism the last thing
that I'm going to talk about is how do
we actually make progress with us so how
do we get away from this Google seems to
think that consciousness is stored
long before you or me came on the scene
went through
you know I'm actually less a conscious
legitimacy so I can do a better diagram
consciousness comes through making
higher higher stages it's much more
complex than than this right in other
words who would read a big thick book to
explain in Campins by their da conflicts
between different consciousnesses
representing different points of view
somehow behind the stage will
incorporate what is right in those
higher points of view and it will also
be a product and part of reacting
against what's wrong in those points of
view so you know this will take place
not only in human perception it will
take place in law it will take place in
political systems it will take place
Hegel thinks even in the development of
religions
it'll happen through art it'll happen
through everything that's important to
human beings through economic
organization all these different things
there'll be some sort of conflict of
perspectives and consciousness in the
broad sense including all of us we'll
have to find some way around that and it
will reach a higher stage will that
higher stage the finishing point no
there will be another higher
consciousness that it will come into
conflict with and then it will have to
somehow supersede that conflict and go
further and further and further so this
is a quite complex systemic development
developmental process if you want to
understand where we currently are you
don't just want to you know accept
things for granted then you want your
consciousness to try to encompass all of
these
stages of now that's right we're gonna
look at the master-slave dialectic next
next class I'm not suggesting anybody
get themselves a dungeon basement and
like trying to enslave somebody so that
they can experience it you know that's
not what Hegel saying he said you you
can think this out you can actually wrap
your head around the development of this
and if you think about any of your
professions that you're going into to
truly develop understanding and your
profession is not just to know where it
is currently but also how it got there
now just so that you know those who are
doomed doomed those who don't study
history are doomed to repeat its
mistakes not just for that reason but
because that's what it means to actually
have a full understanding of X so you
know for example fashion right fashion
is there are certain constants that
aren't there certain things you can
teach us principles that you're getting
in your classes I hope all right they're
not just saying all right everybody
activity time there's some basic
principles and how those develop those
develop through somebody saying I think
it's this way another person saying no I
think it's this way well let's see if we
can develop a more encompassing
systematic view now is that the final
stage no not yet
let's keep going on what about education
you think you know we're finished
figuring out what's going on in
education those of you that are
considering F majors and that theory
changes every five years
it's kind of bad actually doesn't have a
lot of understanding of its own history
too by the way
you know the history of the discipline
even historians need to know the history
of their discipline that's called
historiography and how do you make sense
of this you can think of this also in
terms of more personal things your
family's history does your family
history mean something you know do you
start out just by saying well mom and
dad they're just mom and dad you know
they're just that way
how do they get to be that way they
developed just like you're developing
now
not exactly the same way maybe you guys
are advances beyond your mouth yet
hopefully you are right
hopefully its generation gets better
than better that would be what Hagel is
calling this is the process we need
dialectic so that's an awful lot to take
in I think so I think we'll leave up
here do you feel somewhat better
grounded in what's going on in this this
piece of anything make sense any any
pieces come together for you and then it
did something